il y a un nom la famille ali allouche
posé ses valises à brossard et le
marathon commencée papier appartement
épicerie docteur notions de français
bref une nouvelle vie sont ils devenus
totalement autonome où en est leur
français et leur optimisme quant à leur
avenir ici est il toujours aussi grand
tous les matins je sautais ses tares 30
je prends l'autobus
je vais à l'école
l'école de frasier le commencions à 8 h
15 jusqu'à trois heures après m
c'est arrivé au canada c'est le son par
mois je ne comprends pas
mais maintenant je compris quelques
baies je fais je vais faire l'épicerie
si j'ai fait à l'aller brutale
c'est une classe de francisation alpha
c'est un niveau 2 ce sont des
des étudiants qui en général ont 9
points 8 ans de scolarité et moins dans
leur pays dans leur langue maternelle
je m'appelle s'agit de recherche
l'enseignante de francisation au centre
camille de laura longuet le convoi la
lecture l'écriture décodage décembre
phonétique
des fois ça peut être aussi juste savoir
comment être à l'école pour ceux qui ont
pas été là très souvent dans leur pays
bonjour thomas après elles prennent
d'emprunt c'est bien je travaille tu
penses dans combien de temps après
madame boy c'est ce qui le rendait
impossible courage la confiance de
sortir peut-être un peu plus puis de
rencontrer plus de personnes faire plus
de choses à l'extérieur
utiliser le crayon comme ça s'il ya eu
une erreur sont toujours très content de
venir et d'apprendre souvent ce qui est
plus difficile c'est que c'est lié à
leur vécu à l'art histoire c'est
difficile devant l'arrivée dans la
classe du lycée soucis donc ceux qui ont
des problèmes à la maison des problèmes
financiers ou la famille dans leur pays
d'origine c'est ça qui sont les fils et
de plus se concentrer puis d'oublier ça
ibrahim ont un sens tic
il ya des passages plus difficiles début
d'année plus difficile ça a été beaucoup
mieux que moi ces derniers temps c'est
ça allait moins bien la croatie c'est
que vous ne regardez pas vous faire s'il
vous plaît la vuvuzela chanson les
chansons françaises et qu'est-ce que les
deux problèmes avec le
l'appartement tasse est obligatoire si
il ya un problème pour g koné qu'est-ce
que j'ai posées okaya c'est assez
exceptionnel qu'elle ait pu se rendre si
vite au niveau 4 parce que c'est quand
même difficile pour quelqu'un qui a très
peu de scolarité je m'appelle sylvie
barthez je suis enseignant de français
langue seconde à l'école camille laurens
à queen's park sur la rive sud
elle se débrouille très bien c'est une
personne qui est très motivé qui est
vraiment qui veut apprendre qu'il veut
se débrouiller au québec pour 1,5 si
lourd et l'école c'est je le trouve très
bon ami très bonne classe très bon
professeur tout ne parle pas seulement
les français mais pas les choses
ce swing attention ici c'est mieux parce
que si il vient d avoir
j'ai parlé à rhin je vais parler en
europe parce que c'est comme ça pas de
choix des shadoks côté lula y faire le
tri au caire après que choisit non ça a
dit ok maintenant à toi tu m'as pas à
faire placer ma nationale doit je
l'espère pas de ma personnalité aussi
mec parce que ses importantes dettes et
les personnes 2
de le donner en corner
attention à ma personne je n'ai pas
conduit jamais avant c'est dingue jours
pour l'autre personne je pense ce qu'il
montre bien manger bien dormir les
jouets de toutes les caisses qui se
passe avec moi dans l'école je parlais
avec ce matin chantal aujourd'hui
l'examen chantale j'aime mieux ne pas le
faire dit elle de faire pas bien
oui on parle pas souvent de son école
puis à la faculté non demande à aller
travailler
[Musique]
le soir car hiver la maison j'ai joué
avec mon fils nous en jean et après donc
des fois tu trouves ça dure un peu
cheetah bennati loi découle baydan anne
marie comeau toutes mes limites
si mon pays et bien maintenant quatre
mois
de nouveau il est mort dans le gard je
n'aime pas l'école j'ai même pas canada
je n'aime pas tout même pas serré parce
que les gens commencent enfin pourquoi
pour la guerre tellement
une main de maître non mais c'est
maintenant ma nature nouvel adam a
confié à baden baden et humaine
je fais un cours d'arabe pour les
enfants erick aybar ça jean vous aimez
ça vous donne des coups jeu m'a dit j'ai
un projet je dis c'est quoi il m'a dit
je veux apprendre l'arabe aux enfants
qui en ont envie
bonjour mon nom iba dia je suis une amie
de rokhaya j'ai connu depuis une année
c'est important pour eux pour moi pour
mes enfants d'apprendre l'arabe
d'apprendre leur langue maternelle
et puis c'est une richesse pour eux
comme pour moi
finie la longue alors c'est très beau je
suis pas malade je pense qu'aujourd'hui
rokhaya éleveurs elle veut donner elle
veut redonner à tous ceux qui lui en
donner elle veut
bâtir le québec de demain elle veut
faire ça port vers son avenir ici pour
l'instant coiffeuse ou enseignante mais
elle ne cache pas qu'un jour elle
aimerait retourner vivre chez elles
là où elle est née vu la situation elle
n'y croit guère
elle reprend son sourire pour son fils
et pour son avenir à lui
[Musique]